glenn greenwald has been watching
carefully he's an independent journalist
who writes on sub stack and you should
read his stuff because it's excellent he
joins us tonight glenn thanks so much
for coming on what do you make of this
this this realignment or was it a
previous alignment what are we looking
at
i think it's worth first of all
remembering and i i know that you
remember i started writing about
politics in 2005 so i do how liberals
used to be overflowing with so much
hatred and contempt for george bush they
frequently compared him to adolf hitler
claimed his family was crucial to the
rise of the nazi party claimed something
i agree with that he's a war criminal
who belongs at the hague said he was so
filled with racism that he purposely
allowed new orleans to drown because so
many black people live there and every
liberal i know believes that george bush
stole at least one election and maybe
even two both in 2000 and 2004. so
basically they concocted a person you
can't get much worse than that and yeah
suddenly in the trump years as he began
lightly criticizing trump they began
saying things like you know what i
didn't agree with george bush all the
time but i never questioned his
character and his values and his
patriotism but this weekend it turned
into this love fest i mean they they
dripped with effusive praise for him
because what he said there that
essentially the 9 11 attacks that he was
there to commemorate are the same as the
three-hour riot on january 6 and more
importantly that the people who did 9 11
al qaeda
are similar or identical to
kind of the same foul spirit as he put
it trump supporters essentially and that
they ought to be treated the same
a war on terror against al qaeda now a
domestic war on terror against your
fellow citizens is music to the ears of
american liberals because they want
nothing more than a new domestic war on
terror than treating their political
adversaries like the bush administration
treated al qaeda it's such a lunatic and
extreme thing to say to compare it's
like hitler comparisons i mean
to compare people whose politics you
don't like in the united states who
haven't killed anybody so far as i know
to osama bin laden why is that not
instantly disqualifying just because of
the overstatement
the reason is because it is a political
priority and i probably have spent more
time reporting on this this year than
any other topic it is a political
priority of the political class to
launch a new domestic war on terror you
can go back to before january 6 to
november of 2020 and see articles in the
wall street journal where joe biden was
saying my top priority as president once
i get inaugurated will be to combat
domestic extremism once january 6
happened that became the pretext for
doing it like a lot of neocons wanted to
invade iraq before 9 11 911 happened and
then they got to use that as the pretext
that's what they're using january 6 it's
demented to compare 9 11 and january 6
but it's so central to the agenda of the
security state the democratic party to
essentially initiate a surveillance
regime a detention regime against people
on the right who are against the
establishment and they're already doing
it they put people on the no-fly list
the kind of defining feature of the
first war on terror want to do new
legislation that gives the fbi and the
cia new powers spending lots more money
on law enforcement this war on terror is
crucial to them
i think you're exactly right and it's
not just going to be people on the right
it will it's any any dissent anyone who
opposes the regime i think that would
include you too glenn greenwald so good
luck thank you for coming on tonight